at length my mother would say to me now
don't stay here all day you can go up to
your room if you are too hot
or too hot outside get a little fresh
air first don't start reading
immediately after your food now it go
and sit down beside the pump in its
trough ornamented here and there like a
gothic font with a salamander which
impressed on the rough stone the mobile
relief of its tapering allegorical body
on the bench without a back in the shade
of a lilac tree in that little corner of
the garden which opened through a
service door on to the rue de salta
scrape and from whose neglected soil
there rose in two stages jutting out
from the house itself and as it were a
separate building my aunts back kitchen
one could see it's red tile full floor
gleaming like porphyry it seemed not so
much the cave of France woz as a little
Temple of Venus it would be overflowing
with the offerings of the dairy man the
food arraya the greengrocer come
sometimes from distant villages to
dedicate to the goddess the first fruits
of their fields and its roof was always
crowned with a cooing dove in earlier
days I did not linger in the sacred
grove which surrounded this temple for
before going upstairs to read I used to
steal into the little sitting-room that
my uncle adolphe a brother of my
grandfather and all an old soldier would
retired from the service as a major
occupied on the ground floor a room
which even when it's opened windows let
in the heat if not actually the Rays of
the Sun which seldom penetrated so far
would never fail to admit that oddly
cool odor suggestive at once a woodlands
and the osteon regime which sets the
nostrils quivering when one goes into an
abandoned shooting Lodge but for some
years now I had not gone into my uncle
Adolf sanctum he no longer came to
compre on account of a quarrel which had
arisen between him and my family through
my fault in the following circumstances
once or twice a month in paris i used to
be sent to pay him a visit as he was
finishing his luncheon wearing a plain
help pack of coat and waiting upon
waited upon by his manservant in a
working jacket of striped linen purple
and white he would complain that I had
not been to see
long time that he was being neglected
you'd offer me a biscuit or tangerine
and we would go through a drawing room
in which no one ever said whose fire was
never lighted whose walls were decorated
with gilded moldings and ceiling painted
blue in imitation of the sky and its
furniture upholstered in satin as that
my grandparents only yellow then then he
we would enter what he called his study
a room whose walls were hung with prints
we showed against a dark background a
plump and rosy goddess driving a chariot
we're standing upon the globe or wearing
a star on her brow pictures which were
popular under the Second Empire because
there was thought to be something about
them that suggested Pompeii which were
then generally despised in which are now
becoming fashionable again for one
single and consistent reason
notwithstanding all the others that are
advanced namely that they suggest the
Second Empire and there I would stay
with my uncle until his man came with a
message from the coachman asking him at
what time he would like the carriage my
uncle would then become lost in
meditation well his servants stood there
again not daring to disturb him by the
least movement here is the curiously
awaiting his answer which never varied
for in the end after a supreme crisis of
hesitation my uncle would utter
infallibly the words a quarter past to
which the serving would echo with
amazement but without disputing them a
quarter past two very good sir I'll go
and tell me at this date I was a lover
of the theater a platonic lover since my
parents have not yet allowed me to enter
one and so inaccurate was the picture I
had formed in my mind's eye of the
pleasures to be enjoyed there that I
almost believed each of the spectators
looked as through a stereoscope and a
seed that existed for himself alone
though similar to the thousand other
scenes presented to the rest of the
audience
visually every morning I would hasten to
the Moores column to see what new plays
it announced nothing could be more
disinterested or happier than the
daydreams with which these announcements
filled my imagination daydreams which
were conditioned by the associations of
the words forming the titles of the
plays and also by the color of the bills
still damp and wrinkle toothpaste on
which those words stood out nothing
unless it were such strange titles as
testimony Distasio Giotto or Oedipus Rex
inscribed not on the green bills of the
sephora comic but on the wine colored
bills of the comedy fall says nothing
seemed to me to differ and more
profoundly from the sparkling white
plume of the demo dhawan than the sleek
mysterious satin of the dominant law and
since my parents had told me that for my
first visit to the theater I should have
to choose between these two pieces I
would study exhaustively and in turn the
title of one in the title of the other
for these were all that I knew but
either attempting to snatch from each a
foretaste of the pleasure it promised
and to compare this with the pleasure
all agents in the other until in the end
I succeeded in conjuring up such a vivid
and compelling pictures of on the one
hand a play of dazzling arrogance and on
the other a gentle velvety play that I
was as little capable of deciding which
of them I should prefer to see if at the
dinner table I have been obliged to
choose between rice a la impetus and the
famous creme of chocolate all my
conversations with my friends bore upon
actors whose art although as yet I had
no experience of it was the first of all
its number of forms in which art itself
allowed me to anticipate its enjoyment
between when afters tricks of intonation
and inflection and another's the most
trifling differences would strike me as
being of an incalculable importance from
what I had been told of them I would
arrange them in order of talent and
lists which I used to recite to myself
all day and which ended up by hardening
in my brain and hampering it by their
move ability and later in my school days
whenever I ventured in class as soon as
the Masters head was turned to
communicate with some new friend I'd
always begin by asking him
whether he had already been to the
theater and whether he agreed that our
greatest actor was go our second alone
eh and so on and if in his judgment
velvet came below to mom or Dylan able
coca-cola the sudden volatility which
the name of coca-cola forsaking at
stoney and rigidity would acquire in my
mind and were two up to second place the
miraculous agility the fecund
imagination innovation with which the
name Dylan II would suddenly be endowed
to enable it to slip down to fourth
would stimulate and fertilize my brain
with a sense of a budding and blossoming
life but if the thought of actors
preoccupied me so if the sight of mobile
coming out of the Teatro francais when
afternoon had plunged me into the throes
and sufferings of love how much more did
the name of a star blazing outside the
doors of the theater how much more seen
through the window of a broom passing by
the streets its horses headbands decked
with roses that the face of a woman who
I took to be an actress leave me in a
state of troubled excitement impotently
and painfully trying to form a picture
of her private life I classified the
most distinguished in order of talent
Sarah Bernhardt Burma Bartee Madeleine
brohan jeans Sam re but I was interested
in the mall now my uncle knew many of
them personally and also ladies in
another class not certainly
distinguishes from actresses in my mind
he used to entertain him at his house
and if we went to see him on certain
days only that was because on the other
days ladies might come whom his family
could not very well have met so they at
least thought for my uncle on the
contrary was only too willing to pay
pretty widows who had perhaps never been
married and countesses whose high
sounding titles were probably no more
than nom de guerre the compliment of
presenting them to my grandmother or
even of presenting to them some of the
family jewels propensity which had
already embroiled him in more more than
once with my grandfather often if the
name of some actress were mentioned in
conversation I would hear my father say
to my mother with a smile one of your
uncle's friends and thinking of the
weary and fruitless negotiate and met
and go through perhaps for years on end
on the doorstep of some such lady who
refused to answer their letters and had
them sent packing by the hall Porter it
struck me that my uncle could have
spared from such torments a youngster
like me by introducing him to the
actress unapproachable why all the world
who was for him an intimate friend